Les chirurgiens insère un microscope dans le poivron,
et ils font ce qu'on appelle une « ablation des pépins ».
(Rires)
Ils utilisent ce microscope pour retirer les pépins avec une petite pince.
Et c'est une façon de leur faire acquérir
les rudiments de cette intervention.
Ils entrent donc dans le modèle d'apprentissage,
en observant leurs collègues,
en faisant l'intervention puis en l'enseignant,
en attendant l'arrivée des patients.
Nous pouvons faire bien mieux.
Nous sommes en train de fabriquer des reproductions d'enfants
afin que les chirurgiens et leurs équipes s'entraînent
de la manière la plus pertinente possible.
Voyez plutôt.
Voici mon équipe
avec l'équipe d'ingénieurs du Programme de Simulation.
C'est une incroyable équipe.
Ils sont ingénieurs en mécanique ;
ici, ce sont des dessinateurs.
Ils prennent les données primaires reçues du scanner et de l'IRM,
les transforment en informations digitales,
les animent,
les rassemblent dans les composants de l'enfant lui-même,
analysent en surface les composants de l'enfant qui ont été moulés,
selon le type d'intervention,
et procèdent à l'extraction de ces informations digitales
sur une imprimante 3D de pointe,
qui nous permet d'imprimer les composants
de l'anatomie de l'enfant, au micron près.
Ici,
on imprime le crâne de cet enfant
dans les heures précédant l'intervention.
Mais nous n'aurions pas pu faire ce travail
sans nos chers amis de la Côte Ouest, à Hollywood.
Ce sont des personnes extrêmement talentueuses
qui arrivent à reproduire la réalité.
Ce n'était pas un grand bond pour nous.
Plus nous allons dans ce domaine,
plus il est clair pour nous que nous faisons du cinéma.
Nous réalisons des films,
mais nos acteurs ne sont pas acteurs.
Ils sont médecins et infirmiers.
Voici quelques photos de nos chers amis de Fractured FX
à Hollywood,
vainqueurs d'un Emmy-award pour leurs effets spéciaux.
Voici Justin Raleigh et son groupe --
ce n'est pas un de nos patients --
(Rires)
mais l'illustration de leur superbe travail.
Nous avons collaboré et fusionné notre expérience,
amenant leur groupe à l'Hôpital pédiatrique,
envoyant notre groupe à Hollywood
et discutant
du développement de ces types de simulateurs.
Je vais vous montrer une reproduction de cet enfant.
Vous remarquerez ici que chaque cheveu sur la tête de l'enfant est reproduit.
D'ailleurs, voici à nouveau cette reproduction --
mes excuses aux personnes sensibles,
mais c'est une reproduction et une simulation
de l'enfant qui doit être opéré.
Voilà la membrane dont nous avons parlé,
à l'intérieur du cerveau de cet enfant.
Nous allons voir d'un côté, le patient réel
et de l'autre, le simulateur.
Le microscope, avec sa petite camera, doit se frayer un chemin
et c'est cela que vous voyez.
Il doit faire un petit trou dans cette membrane
pour drainer le LCR.
Je ne vais pas vous demander de distinguer le simulateur du réel.
Le simulateur est à droite.
Les chirurgiens peuvent désormais créer des opportunités d'entraînement,
réaliser ces interventions autant de fois qu'ils voudront,
jusqu'à ce qu'ils se sentent à l'aise.
Ensuite seulement pourront-ils opérer l'enfant.
Ne nous arrêtons pas là.
Nous savons que l'important n'est pas la compétence seule,
mais la combinaison de cette compétence avec une équipe qui délivre ce traitement.
Nous nous sommes tournés vers la Formule 1.
Voici un technicien qui remplace un pneu
et qui répète cette action plusieurs fois sur cette voiture.
Ce geste va rapidement être intégré
aux exercices réalisés en équipe,
à l'organisation complète du changement de pneus
et du retour de la voiture sur le circuit.
Nous avons adapté cette méthode au secteur de la santé
et ce que vous allez voir est une opération simulée.
Nous avons pris ledit simulateur,
nous l'avons amené dans le bloc opératoire de l'Hôpital pédiatrique,
et ces personnes, ces équipes chirurgicales locales,
s'entraînent à réaliser l'intervention avant qu'elle n'ait lieu.
Il s'agit d'opérer deux fois
en une seule incision.
Regardez.
Membre de l'Équipe Chirurgicale 1 : Tête en bas ou vers le haut ?
MEC 2 : Pouvez-vous baisser à 10 ?
MEC 3 : Et baisser la table ?
MEC 4 : Table baissée.
MEC 3 : C'est bien la réaction d'un vaisseau sanguin.
Ciseaux, s'il vous plaît.
MEC 5 : Je prends les gants, de 8 à 8 1/2, j'arrive.
MEC 6 : Parfait, merci.
Peter Weinstock : C'est génial.
La deuxième étape est essentielle :
elle consiste à débriefer immédiatement avec ces équipes.
Nous avons la même technologie
utilisée pour les programmes Lean et Six Sigma.
Nous discutons des facteurs de réussite,
mais surtout,
des facteurs d'échec,
et des corrections possibles.
Puis, on recommence.
C'est une phase essentielle d'exercice et de réflexion.
Revenons à notre cas.
Toujours cet enfant,
mais je vais vous décrire les soins qu'il a reçus
à l'Hôpital pédiatrique.
Il est né à trois heures du matin.
A deux heures du matin,
nous avons formé l'équipe,
utilisé le modèle anatomique,
amélioré par les scanners et autres imageries,
puis nous l'avons présenté à l'équipe
dans un bloc de simulation.
C'est cette équipe qui allait réaliser l'intervention réelle plus tard.
Ils ont donc réalisé la procédure.
En voici un extrait.
Ceci n'est pas une incision réelle.
L'enfant n'a pas encore vu le jour.
Vous imaginez ?
Désormais, les conversations avec les familles
aux soins intensifs de l'Hôpital pédiatrique de Boston
sont totalement différentes.
Imaginez cette conversation :
non seulement nous traitons fréquemment cette pathologie,
et nous avons déjà pratiqué l'intervention
que va subir votre enfant,
mais nous l'avons déjà réalisée sur un modèle exact de votre enfant.
Nous l'avons réalisée il y a deux heures,
et l'avons répétée 10 fois.
Nous sommes donc prêts à passer au bloc opératoire.
C'est une technologie innovante en médecine :
un exercice en conditions réelles.
Une préparation à l'intervention réelle.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)